let's get to some audience questions
first one hey David are there any
countries in the world that you see as
leading indicators of worldwide
political shifts listen it's the United
States if we have to pick a single
country a lot of what you see in the
United States is indicative of changes
that are happening in sort of like the
Western democracies but lately other
than the total atrocity that is the
debasement of the culture and democracy
as a result of Donald Trump being
President of the United States the
right-wing nationalists rise in a number
of European countries as a whole it's
not it's not just what's happening in
Poland it's not just what's happening in
Germany the fact that in a lot of these
countries you're seeing in both Western
and more Eastern European type countries
a rise in white nationalism and
nationalistic xenophobic anti-immigrant
type parties that's a pretty significant
shift to me and I know that being in the
United States being part of the West
we're not as keyed in to changes that
are happening in southern African
countries because we just we're ignorant
to it I think that's the right word we
just don't get as much news about that
and there may well be but I think sort
of in our world of the Western
democracies that right wing shift in
Europe combined with Donald Trump is
very very scary and it signifies a
broader worldwide trend yeah and even
the United Kingdom choosing to pull out
of the European Union exemplifies that
as well and you can see it beyond just
Europe right it's Rodrigo Duterte in the
Philippines
yes it's air21 and Turkey right there's
a lot of these rises going on in the
world right now and it's pretty
terrifying I know a lot of people won't
agree with me but what we're seeing
continuing in Venezuela that we saw
under Hugo Chavez but now also under
Nicolas Maduro will probably lose five
members because I even mentioned this
but that's also very problematic to me
and it's you know Latin America is
another it's another thing it's another
animal all together and it's one that I
pay much more attention to than for
example what goes on in Africa or even
Asia because I'm from Argentina but
that's been a wave that's been ridden
for now decades
the United States pushing regime change
in many cases and so on and so forth but
it doesn't really represent a shift in
the way that the white nationalist
extremist identitarian types in Europe
are scaring the hell out of me yeah and
unfortunately there's no real way to
predict where it's going right I mean we
think it's getting more right-wing and
authoritarian around the world right now
yeah doesn't mean that in 10 years it'll
be the same thing no but 10 years is a
long time to do some damage right 10
years is enough elections in a lot of
those European countries in two years
and three years four or five six we're
by 10 years imagine that there is just
like a massive leftward swing in ten
years you get in a country like the
United States maybe a younger average
population as baby boomers get it get
older no I don't know exactly when it
would be but ten years is a long time
and that's why we laugh when Trump signs
some stupid executive order saying we're
gonna do the opposite of what Obama did
whatever it is and it's not really gonna
do anything we laugh or we say it's a
waste of time it's a waste of money the
climate change stuff Supreme Court picks
damaging relationships with many of
these European allies ten years will
probably not be enough to undo it
remember Trump has like another three or
two and a half years he might get four
beyond that we're probably gonna need
ten years just to get back to where we
were eighteen months ago some of those
small island countries will be gone by
then they won't even be there yeah I
mean it's it's it's stunning so I don't
look at any one country but I think in
the last five years that move in Europe
has been very very concerning to me